[Musique]
des images inédites dans l'intimité du
troisième reich
voici le dernier ouvrage de riz ce
dessinateur est rédacteur en chef à
charlie hebdo
un titre qui interpelle hitler dans mon
salon
photos privées d'allemagne 1933-1945
rice a récupéré la plupart de ses photos
sur internet une vision sidérant du
nazisme au quotidien ces photos
proviennent majoritairement du front de
l'est
elles représentent les tranches de vie
des tranches de vie qui peuvent mettre
mal à l'aise le lecteur étrangement les
jambes des comme ici même salut mais sur
un véhicule moins rapide
là une scène burlesque ou de soldats
jouent à la guerre
petite mise en scène humoristique entre
soldats
ici un simulacre d'exécution étonnante
légende voilà l'un des reproches que
nous pourrions faire à l'auteur ces
images ne comportent aucune indication
précise nous ne savons rien sur ces
hommes de leur histoire du contexte
alors rice qui a refusé l'aide
d'historiens invente
c'est un parti pris qui l'assument
quelques pages plus loin des photos
terrifiante nous savons simplement qu'il
s'agit de russes 5 pendu des civils des
militaires des résistants aucune réponse
[Musique]
le risque de ces chroniques ordinaire du
nazisme pourrait être une banalisation
du mal rendre humain des nazis ces
photos nous montrent des anonymes des
hommes des soldats des tortionnaires des
pères dans leur quotidien une sorte
d'album de famille
nous entrons malgré nous dans leur
intimité un peu gêné
rice de ce côté là a réussi son pari
ces barbares avait une vie c'est
désormais au lecteur de juger du bien
fondé d'un tel ouvrage françois ses
voyelles rice bonsoir nous venons veut
voir une présentation de christophe
kulikov ski à propos du livre qui est
l'objet de notre polémique de ce soir il
clair dans mon salon je vais y revenir
tout de suite pensé à daniel vous êtes
historienne de la photographie vous êtes
l'auteur de ce splendide livre ce très
bon du studio harcourt 1934 2009 aux
idiots sion ncc nicolas chaudun c'est ça
très bien exact avant de poser la
question de ce
du projet qu'il ya derrière ce livre
parce que c'est important de savoir
pourquoi vous l'avez fait dans quelles
conditions comment ces photos sont venus
juste à vous et à quelques singularités
j'allais dire éditorial à savoir que
votre préface la préface est signée
l'éditeur donc on ne sait pas trop ce
qu'il en est et votre nom n'apparaît pas
sur la couverture alors dites moi un peu
ses partis pris éditoriaux à quoi il
correspond
c'est à dire que moi je comment dire
ce qui m'intéressait c'était de
restituer un peu photo que j'ai
découvert un peu par hasard
sur le net et c'est plutôt le matériel
qui m'intéressait enfin c'est plutôt de
restituer ce que ce que les gens avaient
chez eux en allemagne dans les années 30
dans leurs albums photos et comment ils
sont comiques photographier chez eux
quoi c'est une vision où ils ont privé
de cette période quoi je pense que
l'historienne que vous êtes à peut-être
quelques remarques à faire sur la
méthode non et bien évidemment comme
vous venez de le dire il ya un premier
temps qui est une recherche de
maternelle le matériau on là vous nous
dites deviennent ces photos quand on a
le livre on ne sait pas d'où viennent
ces photos en fait ils sont achetés ce
rythme sera acheté sur ebay mais cela on
ne le sait pas et puis d'autre part
quand on met ensemble des images ont
créé du discours on passe du matériau et
part sur internet a eu un discours
la première photo la photo de couverture
on est dans la première partie de
l'ouvragé
on est dans une partie du département
excessivement privé c'est à dire c'est
ce que l'on appelle la photo de famille
alors elle a une particularité cette
photo de famille c'est que elle et elle
provient de personnes qui ont participé
activement au mouvement d'asie parce que
ils sont et son ss ou bien simplement
ils appartiennent à la wehrmacht et
alors le discours continue naturellement
avec la succession des images mais
surtout avec les gens d'accord là c'est
à dire qu'il ya beaucoup de strates de
photos d'eux
les gens qui sont pas exactement
identique alors par exemple j'ai gamin
membre des jeunesses hitlériennes
voici un peu enrobé voilà le terme un
peu enrobé je ne sais pas moi qu'ils kg
mais c'est dans la succession que je
vais découvrir que parfois c'est la
légende c'est indiqué c'est indiqué il
ya il ya une honnêteté il ya une
honnêteté moi je mets pas en cause
l'honnêteté mais simplement il ya des ya
des niveaux très différents
alors par exemple on peut aller d'un
commentaire personnel un peu ironique à
la façon finalement de d'un discours qui
pouvait être fait par les familles elles
mêmes mais on n'est pas toujours du même
point de vue et c'est de faire réagir le
risque probable expliqué d'avoir le
parti pris de ces légendes leur style
leur rédaction lors que c'est à dire que
ce qui est publié ce sont des photos et
parfois c'est vrai que j'ai envie que le
lecteur prennent le temps de bien
regarder les photos et de temps en temps
je fais des légendes
peut-être qu'ils peuvent sembler un peu
personnel mais qui essaye quand même
d'attirer un peu l'attention sur
certains aspects de ce cas dans la photo
ayant moi ce que je veux c'est que les
lecteurs
regarde chaque individu séparément
essayent d'imaginer qui était ce
personnage
les seuls éléments qu'on la sait ce que
c'est ce que la photo donne donc on peut
pas aller au delà dans l'interprétation
mes coups - électeurs prennent le temps
de bien garder les considérer comme un
objectif simplement objectif c'est juste
pour c'est juste pour lecteurs ne passe
pas trop vite sur la photo et regarde
quand même certains détails qu'il ya pas
qu un aspect historique la doit aussi à
l'assaut des sentiments le dérapage et
esthétique mais une photo c'est aussi
une construction de l'image mais en même
temps à moi plutôt que ce commentaire
par exemple vous faites allusion à
l'organisation de nsk cas ben c'est quoi
la le lecteur et se dit c'est quoi et
vous lui dites pas ce qu'on pourrait les
expliciter internationale se salissent
kraft food c'est une organisation
je crois de mécaniciens au départ c'est
en dehors des mécaniciens je crois
qu'ils étaient dans le parti c'est
devenu une organisation d'une vraie
précise de type et c'est soit ça voilà
et
et qu'il a d'ailleurs été jugée comme
criminelle contre lui même c'est
important de le savoir important de ne
pas le savoir c'est s'est passé dire car
c'est tout pareil que dire que bon quand
vous on peut effectivement détailler
chaque photo donner des informations
historiques pour chaque photo
on voit par exemple demander un char
husky effondré alors je me dis qu'est-ce
qu'il faut que je dise quel est le type
de charlton avant mais est-ce qu'il faut
que je donne tous les indices au point
de faire perdre de vue aux lecteurs
l'objectif du lift qui est de montrer
comment les gens qui ont vécu cette
période se voyait et se prenaient en
photo
j'illustre gym hamstra voici une photo
dans une série de photos sur le le salut
nazi et la légende c'est même ça lui met
sur un véhicule moins rapide oui c'est
un fait
oui on peut dire c'est ta fête oui alors
moi je trouve que ces images elles sont
franchement très intéressant elle montre
un autre visage qu'on ne connaît pas ou
en tout cas les gens souvent ne
connaissent pas mais on c'est de la
nitroglycérine saisi ma ligne ça veut
dire ça veut dire que en tant
qu'historienne à chaque fois que je vais
interviewer des gens qui ont participé
ou dont la famille a participé
c'est toujours très compliqué de faire
parler des gens c'est une mine ça aussi
pour vous donc
alors pour l'historien c'est une mine
lui
montrer qu'on ne pas montrer et quand
même moi je trouve pourquoi c'est une
bombe pour vous parce que finalement
c'est quand même dit vous voyez c'est
toujours comme vous et moi quoi jours
des fêtes de famille ils sont quand ces
gens mais de la même humanité c'est ce
qu'il ya dans votre dans votre passé la
préface mois le discours de la préface
me semble très différent de votre
discours parce que ans 8e deuxième
partie c'est les photos c'est alors
cette fois ci les soldats au front en
tout cas sur le champ opérationnel et là
vous ne vous n'expliquez pas pourquoi
les y attend de photos nous mais on ne
sait par la com pourquoi finalement
comment ils pouvaient photographier dans
quelles conditions il n'y a pas une
petite laine pour expliquer c'est vrai
que les comment dire la fabrication de
ces photos la raison de l'existence de
ces photos je ne suis pas tellement
attardé pour savoir pourquoi ces photos
étaient prises mais c'est plutôt je
dirais quand vous dites dans quelles
circonstances pourquoi les soldats
prenez autant de photos
mais c'est plutôt moi j'irai pourquoi il
prenait ces photos là et pourquoi les
prenais de cette manière là moi chaque
fois ce qui m'a dit sous quand je
choisis c'est une photo je choisis une
photo soit j'en ai vu quand même
énormément et j'en ai certainement vu
que je n'ai pas choisi que vous auriez
peut-être que vous mourriez peut-être
dit vous auriez dû vous écartez par
exemple sauf quelle base g j'ai toujours
essayé de prendre des photos ou comment
dire on pouvait voir le rapport que le
photographe entretiens avec son sujet
c'est à dire comment le photographe se
positionne par rapport à ce qu'il voit
doit on revenir sur vos intentions à
risque parce que on a parlé de cette
note de l'éditeur
là on a parlé de cette humanité il est
écrit donc dans cette note de l'éditeur
l'éditeur c'est vous c'est week-end les
7/9 bien ça aurait été bien en acier je
trouve
ils ont beau accrocher leurs chaussures
au lustre des synagogues
gif le les femmes humiliées les enfants
défilé sous une tête d'abord une sont ni
des monstres ni des pervers mais des
gens insignifiant des bidasses des
gamins sans méchanceté particulière qui
savent ce qu'ils font mais n'y pense pas
mais oui ils ne réfléchissent pas ou pas
suffisamment je dis rien
moi ce qui quand je regardais tous ces
photos ce qui ressortait de ces
photos-là constant pour être ces photos
qui espèce de sentiment de légèreté avec
enfin que les justes ces gens qui se
photographie qui photographient les
autres peu de légèreté qu'ils ont avec
cet environnement politique dans lequel
il évolue
comme si tout ça n'était pas grave comme
si chaque photo était fait pour
convaincre le photographe que finalement
rien n'était grave
tout est normal alors on voit bien que
tout est grave et tout est normal
il ya un décalage entre ce qu'ils
essayaient de 2,2 de photographies de
ceux qui essayait de faire pour se
convaincre de cela puisque nous savons
je pense que vous serez d'accord avec la
suite de la citation parce que c'est un
peu ce que vous avez dit sur cette mine
que pouvait représenter ces photos c'est
la grande leçon et la vertu de ce
recueil les barbes à arrêter des humains
comme vous et moi ne pas l'oublier et le
premier enjeu du devoir de mémoire est
ce que vous êtes d'accord jeudi
c'est une question séparée
non moi je suis plus plus plus réservé
aux règles plus réservé par rapport à
cela parce que on a aussi moi j'ai aussi
l'impression que là on me montre dans le
fond globalement peuple allemand en quoi
c'est vous et moi donc c'est peuple
allemand de 33 à 39 martyrs
ah non mais attendez vous le dites pas
que vous dites que c'est des braves
types non mais vanté comme vous et comme
nous et moi comme vous et moi oui
m'enfin c'est pas tous enfin c'est pas
ton peuple est mort juste une
banalisation mois pour moi il ya quand
même une grande banalité tout lien
espèce de nivellement le lot quotidien
le quotidien que vous montrer cette
espèce de 2,2 d'inconscient dette reste
aux yeux de banalités et bien fait qu'
il ya un nivellement bien un événement
celui en fait c'est un tout il ya un
début un milieu et une fin
bon discours comme je vais évidemment un
discours non mais faut aller au bout du
discours c'est un peu moi j'ai dans un
premier temps je dirais que j'ai laissé
et jean se montrer comme il voulait
qu'on les montre donc ce qui vous peut
vous donner l'impression au lecteur de
comprendre ses intentions et de les
décrypter
oui parce qu'il faut aussi faire
confiance à peu à l'intelligence du
lecteur mais aussi j'veux dire quand
même déclic sonné voulait pas non plus
démunis j'ai quand même ajouté à la fin
en annexe des chronologies d'envoi des
chronologies qui sont là ya pas de
d'appréciation personnelle
c'est l'effet des dates qu'il faut à mon
avis avoir quand même en tête pour bien
comprendre ce livre et puis il ya aussi
j'ai publié aussi semble important les
sentences ont été prononcés au tribunal
de nuremberg et mais finalement les
jugements qui ont été portées sur cette
époque au bout du compte il ya un
jugement qui a porté sur cette époque et
qui fait partie du livre
alors justement dans l'erreur c'est de
regarder juste les photos comme ça il
faut pas regarder des photos comme ça il
faut dire les photos com com com et les
textes presque de la même façon avec la
même attention
alors je viens on va parler d'eux et de
pédagogie je demandais à vous
l'historienne si vous êtes d'accord à
une position de pierre assouline qui a
été très très forte qui est un des
premiers donkili c'est du pain béni pour
les négationnistes est ce que vous iriez
jusque là et pendant je serai peut-être
plus mesurée mais quand je dis c'est de
la nitroglycérine oui c'est bien que je
vois les
d'embauché oui c'est ce que je vais vous
poser une question portrait direct
est ce que au cours d'une réimpression
vous allez signer je viens je vais
rectifier si je dois faire imprimer moi
je veux bien rectifié sommes d'accord ça
je n'en ai pas je suis pas fermé au
débat et les critiques d'accord donc
voilà on parlait c'était l'objet de
cette polémique de hitler dans mon salon
aux éditions des échappées nucléaire
dans mon salon photos privées
d'allemagne 1933 à 1945
l'auteur on n'est pas sur la couverture
présérie ça l'auteur et sur la
couverture studio harcourt françoise
denoyelle à super bowl il conseille à
tout un chacun
tiens je verrais bien ça sous le sapin
mois merci beaucoup à vous pour cette
rencontre autour de l'image
[Musique]